from great suffering came a solution  communities serene beautiful places  where disorder became harm the only way  our society can survive is for each of  you to claim your rightful  let him have it  we need saying this dr. Zeko chins up  smiles on  he's the one they all talk everybody  always seems to know my seekers for  finer than myself find them every last  one of them  war is over we can have the luxury of  debating the morality of what we do no  one else can a diamond you you feel  something else for me if I wanted to  hurt you I would have I think we should  all stick together now that we're all  officially fugitives  you  you  my car fired directly up into the eye